>> WELCOME.
IF YOU'VE BEEN PAYING ATTENTION
TO THE NEWS RECENTLY, MANY OF
THE BIG STORIES REVOLVE AROUND
QUESTIONS OF RACE.
INCREASINGLY IN THIS COUNTRY
RACE IS THE HEADLINE.
JUST THIS WEEK ROSEANNE BARR AND
HER SHOW CANCELED ON ABC AFTER
TWEETING AN ATTACK ON VALERIE
JARRETT THAT MANY DESCRIBED AS
RACIST.
STARBUCKS, THE COFFEE RETAILER,
CLOSED MORE THAN 8,000 RETAIL
STORES IN ORDER TO EDUCATE WHITE
EMPLOYEES ABOUT THEIR
UNCONSCIOUS RACISM.
MEANWHILE A BAR IN PORTLAND,
HOSTED A REPARATION HOUR, WHERE
NONWHITE PATRONS BANK FOR FREE.
>> THE GENTRIFIERS OF TODAY ARE
SAYING, OH, THERE'S SO MANY
OLIVE GARDENS I CAN GO TO, SO I
NEED TO GO BACK TO THE CITY, GET
MY LIFE IN THE CITY, BUT I NEED
MY HOT YOGA STUDIO, MY POTTERY
STUDIO, MY STUFF REPRESENTED.
IF YOU INTRUDE ON THAT, I WILL
THEN CALL THE POLICE.
>> MORE AND MORE IT FEELS LIKE
RACIAL DIVISION IS THE SUBTEXT
OF VIRTUALLY EVERYTHING IN THIS
COUNTRY, EVEN TOPICS THAT SEEM
UNRELATED TO ETHNICITY SUDDENLY
ARE RACIALLY FRAUGHT.
THE EFFECT IS A DEEPLY ANGRY AND
DIVIDED NATION, BUT ALSO YOU MAY
HAVE NOTICED A TERRIFIED ONE.
MANY AMERICANS ARE SCARED TO SAY
JUST ABOUT ANYTHING.
ONE FALSE WORD AND YOU COULD BE
DENOUNCED ON TWITTER AND LOSE
YOUR LIVELIHOOD.
IT HAPPENS.
WE SEE IT ALL THE TIME.
BEST IS TO SMILE AND NOD AND
HOPE THE WITCH-HUNT PASSES.
HOW LONG DO WE HAVE TO LIVE THIS
WAY?
HOW DID WE GET HERE IN THE FIRST
PLACE?
JOINING US A LAWYER WHO SERVES
ON THE U.S. COMMISSION ON CIVIL
RIGHTS, WRITTEN A NEW THRILLER,
CALLED "SECOND STRIKE," WHICH I
CAN TELL YOU FIRSTHAND IS
EXCELLENT.
PETER, THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
>> THERE'S SOMETHING STRANGE
GOING ON.
EVEN AS THE COUNTRY BECOMES MUCH
MORE DIVERSE, SOMETHING WE WERE
PROMISED WOULD MAKE THE COUNTRY
MORE HARMONIOUS, THE COUNTRY
SEEMS MORE ON EDGE ABOUT
QUESTIONS OF RACE.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> SEVERAL THINGS ARE GOING ON,
BUT THE OVERRIDING THING IS A
POLITICAL NARRATIVE TO ENHANCE
AN ARGUMENT OR ONE PARTICULAR
SIDE, AND HAS ITS GENESIS IN TWO
THINGS.
FIRST IS THE POLITICAL
ELECTED CHIEFLY, AND SO WE HAVE
A LOT OF THIS DIVISION ON THE
BASIS OF RACE BECAUSE THERE ARE
NO POLICY PRESCRIPTIONS ANYMORE.
IF YOU LISTEN VERY CLOSELY, YOU
DON'T HEAR ANY WORKABLE POLICY
PRESCRIPTIONS, OR VERY FEW
WORKABLE POLICY PRESCRIPTIONS,
BUT WHAT YOU HEAR A LOT OF IT IS
IDENTITY POLITICS.
IN 17 YEARS, WE HAVEN'T HAD MORE
LUCID CONVERSATIONS ABOUT RACE
OR IDENTITY.
THEY'VE GOTTEN INCREASINGLY
SOPHOMORIC, OPAQUE, DRIVEN BY AN
AHISTORICAL NARRATIVE THAT HAS
LITTLE BEARING THAT TRULY
HAPPENED IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
LOOK, THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
THAT IN MY LIFETIME MATTERS OF
RACE AND DISCRIMINATION HAS
GOTTEN DEMONSTRABLY BETTER, IN
WAYS THAT WE COULD NEVER HAVE
IMAGINED.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE INTERACTION
BETWEEN INDIVIDUALS OF VARIOUS
RACES TODAY THEY'VE NEVER BEEN
BETTER.
INDIVIDUALS OF RACES.
WHEN YOU COME TO THE INTERACTION
BETWEEN GROUPS, IT'S BECOME
HOSTILE AND TOXIC, AND IT'S A
FUNCTION OF TRYING TO GET
CERTAIN GROUPS TO HAVE AN
ALLEGIANCE TO A CERTAIN MOVEMENT
OR CERTAIN PARTY FOR POLITICAL
IMPERATIVE.
>> MAY I STEP IN THERE AND BACK
UP FOR A SECOND TO ADDRESS
SOMETHING THAT YOU SAID THAT I
NEVER THOUGHT OF.
THE CONVERSATION IS INCREASINGLY
GENERAL AND LESS SPECIFIC.
SO WHEREAS 30 YEARS AGO PEOPLE
MIGHT SAY, IN ORDER TO CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP IN STANDARD ICED
TESTING, WE NEED TO PUT MORE
MONEY INTO HEAD START, FOR
EXAMPLE.
NOW THE CONVERSATION IS THIS
GROUP IS BAD, IT HAS ALWAYS BEEN
BAD, IT WILL NEVER GET BETTER.
WHY ARE WE HEARING FEWER
SOLUTIONS THAN WE USED TO HEAR?
>> WELL, I THINK FOR A COUPLE OF
REASONS.
ONE AGAIN IS THAT POLITICAL
IMPERATIVE, BECAUSE SOLUTIONS GO
AGAINST HAVING A POLITICAL
ADVANTAGE.
I THINK IT'S ALSO BECAUSE
THERE'S A TENDENCY ON THE PART
OF SOME TO SHUT DOWN OTHERS, TO
CAST OTHERS AS THE OTHER.
AGAIN, THAT'S FOR POLITICAL
IMPERATIVE.
>> RIGHT.
>> BUT YOU'RE AFRAID TO SAY
THINGS THAT ARE DEMONSTRABLY
TRUE.
TO GIVE YOU ONE EXAMPLE, A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO WE HAD A
HEARING AT THE U.S. COMMISSION
ON CIVIL RIGHTS, ALL-DAY
HEARING, EVERYBODY IN THE WORLD
WAS THERE, THE USUAL GROUPS WERE
THERE.
IT WAS A HEARING ON HATE CRIMES
BECAUSE OF THE SPIKE IN HATE
CRIMES SINCE TRUMP HAS BEEN
ELECTED.
BUT FACTS ARE STUBBORN THINGS.
WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
DATA, AND WHEN I ASKED QUESTIONS
OF THIS, AFTER EVERYONE MADE
THESE GRAND PRONOUNCEMENTS ABOUT
HOW HORRIBLE AND HORRIFIC THE
SPIKE IN HATE CRIMES IS, WE HAD
NO HARD EVIDENCE OF SUCH SPIKE.
THE BEST DATA ON THIS COMES FROM
THE BUREAU OF JUSTICE
STATISTICS.
WHAT IT'S SHOWN FOR THE LAST 30
YEARS, THERE'S BEEN A DECLINE IN
HATE CRIMES.
THERE'S BEEN A DECLINE IN ALL
MANNER OF DISCRIMINATION FOR
MORE THAN 30 YEARS.
YET WE HAVE GREATER SENSITIVITY,
HEIGHTENED SENSITIVITY, AND YOU
HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF THIS, WHY
THIS IS THE CASE.
I THINK TO SOME EXTENT IT'S
BECAUSE IT HELPS THE AGENDA OF
CERTAIN GROUPS OF CERTAIN
PARTIES, CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS.
>> SO YOU KEEP HEARING THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE AN HONEST
CONVERSATION ON RACE.
I'M ALWAYS FOR CONVERSATIONS,
PARTICULARLY FOR HONEST ONES.
I WONDER AFTER ALL THESE
CONVERSATIONS IF THE COUNTRY IS
BECOMING MORE DIVIDED.
MAYBE THAT'S EVIDENCE IT'S NOT
WORKING.
DO WE NEED TO TALK LESS ABOUT
RACE OR MORE ABOUT RACE?
DOES THE CONVERSATION IDEA HOLD
UP TO SCRUTINY?
>> TWO THINGS.
TUCKER, I DISAGREE WE'RE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS.
WE ALWAYS HEAR WE NEED TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION, BUT WHAT WE GET IS
ALWAYS HARANGUES, COMING FROM
ONE SIDE, AND MOST DECENT PEOPLE
DUCK THEIR HEADS AND WATCH FOR
INCOMING FIRE.
THEY DON'T WANT TO GET CAUGHT IN
CROSSFIRE.
YOU KNOW IF YOU GO TO COLLEGES,
LAW SCHOOLS, ALMOST ANY
INSTITUTION OF HIGHER LEARNING,
FRANKLY K-12, THERE ARE ONLY
CERTAIN ACCEPTABLE OPINIONS THEY
CAN HAVE, AND STUDENTS ARE
PUNISHED FOR THIS, AND THEY KNOW
HOW TO REACT IN THE CONTEXT OF A
CLASSROOM DEBATE OSTENSIBLY ON
RACE.
THERE'S ONLY ONE ACCEPTABLE
OPINION, AND YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED
TO OFFER OTHER OPINIONS.
THAT DOESN'T FURTHER THE
CONVERSATION.
ONE OTHER POINT --
>> NO.
IT DOESN'T HELP ANYBODY.
I CAN SEE WHY THEY TRY TO SHUT